now thank you for staying with us here
at 6 30 I'm Denise Valdez I'm Brian
Loftus it was Friday Mother's Day
weekend for a Las Vegas mom who
discovered her young daughter was stung
by one of these they're pretty creepy a
scorpion sting sending them for an
overnight stay eventually at the
hospital eight news now reporter Brian
will explains what you need to look out
for as these Critters are coming out of
hiding
this is where it all started when Kim's
daughter was swimming in their pool and
she got close to this ledge it's a bark
scorpion uh it's about the size of I
don't know an inch and a half maybe
when it was in the pool we could barely
see it for Kim shimolewski it was the
last thing she thought could happen to
her five-year-old daughter Kate
she jumped up
uh and she was grabbing at her swimsuit
bottom and I didn't know what happened
at first and then I saw this teeny tiny
clear creature walking on the bottom of
the pool platform
never in a million years did I think uh
scorpions could survive in water Kim
took Kate to the emergency room at
Summerlin Hospital Saturday where she
was given Benadryl told what symptoms to
look out for and sent home but an hour
later she was having involuntary
movements just these little twitches
and then after about five to ten minutes
her body was just kind of like this full
body
um
muscle spasm Kim called 9-1-1 and soon
they were on their way back to the ER
that's where her daughter received three
doses of Anti-Venom and ended up
spending the night into Mother's Day in
the ICU
now Kate has made nearly a full recovery
and she's even jumping back into the
pool we kept the Scorpion for her to
look at and she wants nothing to do with
it the family says they'll be taking
extra precautions before stepping into
the pool as a result of this reporting
in Summerlin Brian will eight news now